おっ
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
私は島根大学生物資源科学部の山本です
今日はラマンとの出会いというお話をします
私はラマン分光法と優勝使って研究を進めています
ラマンというのはインド人物理学者の名前です
ラマン分光法は彼のある発見をきっかけにして発展しました
そしてその発見に対して1930年にはノーベル物理学賞が有色人種としては初めて
授与されました
それでは私たちの研究のなったら
ラマン分光法を使った病気を診断するための研究についてご紹介します
食堂が炎症を起こす食道炎にはいくつか種類があります
その中に好酸球性食道炎という病気があります
私たちはこの病気をラマン分光法を使って診断するための研究を進めています
この病気好酸球性食道炎の食道炎の前についている
好酸球という言葉は5種類ある
白血球のうちの一つの名前です
通常食道粘膜に
好酸球は見られないんですがこの病気になるとたくさん見られます
それでこの名前がついています
この病気の治療方法は確立しています
ですから治療できます
でも通常の
食道炎とは治療方法が違うんです
それで最初にきちんと診断をするということがとても大切になります
診断するためには
明かりのついたカメラ内視鏡
食堂に入れて
調べます
画像見ただけでは診断できないことがあるので
食堂組織の一部を切り取って染色して後で調べます
すると
この病気の患者さんは年寄りの方が多いんですが
年寄りの方は高血圧や
高脂血症の方が多いです
ですから
高齢の方の
あの政権をすると
出血がたくさん起こって
その出血が長く続くために現在問題になっています
でもラマン分光法を用いると
好酸球だけが持っている物質を見ることができます
つまり政権なしに診断できるんです
そのおかげで
この病気の診断は
短い時間で済みますし
患者さんの負担がとても軽くなります
そして診断さえきちんとできれば
適切な治療を行うことによって再び
健康な生活を取り戻すことができます
その他に私たちは癌の診断をラマン分光法で行うための研究も行なっています
近いうちに
世界に先駆けて島根大学医学部附属病院でこんな診断ができる日もくると思います
こんな風に私たち研究者の仕事は我々の生活とは全く関係ないなんていうことはなく皆
さん一人一人の生活と繋がっているんだということどうか覚えておいてください
それではラマン分光法に名前を残している
ラマンとは一体どんな人だったんでしょうか
この人がらまんです
これはインドの切手に乗ったらまんです
ラーマンは正確にはジャン取らせカール
便可たらマン略して cv ラマン
と言います
インドで cv ラマンと行ったら知らない人が居ないっていうくらい有名です
私と一緒に島根大学で働いているインド人研究者に聞いてみたら
ラーマンのことなら小学生の時に学校で習いましたよ
彼のことを知らなインド人はいないんじゃないんですか
とのことでした
ラーマンは19世紀末に南インドで生まれました
そしてインドで教育を受けました
彼は1928年に光の散乱に関する新しい物理現象を発見しました
そしてわずか2年後にはノーベル物理学賞
単独で受賞したんです
彼の発見がどれだけ世界に衝撃を与えたのか
そして
関連する科学分野
いかに大きな期待と影響を与えたのかが分かります
その頃インドはイギリス領でしたからノーベル賞授賞式の時に会場に掲げられていたの
はインド国旗ではなく
ユニオンジャックだったそうです
ラマンがどんな思いでユニオンジャックを見たのか想像するに余りあります
その時イギリス政府への不服所の罪で獄中にあったガンジーから
ラマンに当てて祝前が贈られたとも言われています
これはラマンガ研究に用いた装置のレプリカの写真です
彼が
学長を務めたインド科学大学で私が実際に撮影しました
ラマンが今なおインド人怒
強い尊敬を集め続けているのは
彼が
インド人の
高等教育を進めるためにインドにとどまって
インド人の高等教育の充実に尽くしたからであってただ単に彼がノーベル賞を受賞した
からだけではないと思います
そして彼が
インド科学大学の拡張になりました
インド科学大学っていうのは
インドでは最も権威がある
大学なんですがラーマンが学長になるまでは
基礎科学の研究をする部門はありませんです
ラマンが学長になって初めて
基礎科学の研究をすることができるようになりました
それで先ほど申し上げたようにラーマンはインド人の尊敬を今でも集め続けています
それではラマンが実際に
玉ノーベル賞を受賞するために行った時に使っていた装置はどういうものだったん
でしょうか
これはなかなか立派な装置なんですが非常に簡素なものでした
それではその頭を模式的に表したものをご覧下さい
これは外からの光が入らないように作られた
木の箱暗箱です
蓋を取ると太陽光が装置の奥にまで差し込みます
この図ではレンズは
1万いい
省略されていますが実際の装置では2枚レンズが使われます
装置の奥では液体の入った
ガラス製容器光学せるがあって
その液体で光は産卵されます
その様子をのぞき窓から肉眼で観察すると光が通るむつ
航路が見えます
次に
長波長の光をカットする青いフィルターと
短波長の光をカットする緑色のフィルターをセットすると
太陽光は2枚のフィルターを通ることができる
できず真っ暗になります
次にタンパ長の光をカットする緑色のフィルターを取り外して
のぞき窓の前に移したらどうなると思いますか
先ほどは太陽光は2枚のフィルターを通ることができる
できず真っ暗になったんですから緑のフィルターを除き窓の前に移しても変わらないん
じゃないかと思う方も多いと思います
でも
うっすらと航路が再びに言えるようになりました
なぜでしょうか
ラーマンは
いきたいによって産卵された光の中に
長波長の成分が生じたためと考えました
波長が長波長になった光はタンパ長の光をカットする緑色のフィルターを通ることが
できます
それでまた航路が見えるようになっ
というわけです
もう少し詳しくお話しします
いきたいはたくさんの分子が集まってできています
分身に光が当たると通常は光が進む角度が変わるだけで光の波長は変化しません
でも確率は低いですが光と分子がエネルギーのやり取りをして光の波長が変わることが
あります
ラマーはそのことを実際に観察で確かめたということになります
このことをら漫画
権威ある科学雑誌ネイチャーで発表すると大反響になりました
なぜなら波長が変化した光には分子が持っているいろいろな情報が含まれているから
です
私は大学生の頃にラマン分光学を研究している研究室で学びました
その時に教わった先生から
ラマン分光学っていうのは分子に光をあてて分子に手紙を書いてもらうんだ
そしてその手紙を解読して我々は研究しているんだよ
分子が自分のことを調べて調べてと言ってるって想像してごらんと言われました
分子からの手紙という素敵な言葉は私の先生のそのまた先生に当たる
島之内雄彦先生という物理科学者の言葉だそうです
現在のラマン分光装置は
太陽光のカーリンレーザー光が
暗箱の代わりに分光器がそして肉眼の代わりにデジタルカメラでも使われている
ccs ccd 素子が使われていますでも基本原理はまったく変わっていません
今では弱い光も測定できるようになったので生きた組織や
生きた細胞を傷つけることなく顕微鏡と組み合わせて精密な測定ができるようになり
ました
それで生きた細胞のどこにどんな分子がどれくらい
どんな状態で存在しているのか調べることができるようになりました
それで私は先ほどご紹介したような病気の診断に関する研究ができています
このように研究や技術開発には歴史があってそれはいつも必ず人の手によってなされて
きました
ラマーも発見に至るまできっといろんなことがあったんだと思います
分子からの手紙という素敵な言葉を残してくれた
島之内雄彦先生私の大先輩もきっと試行錯誤の中で分子化の手紙を読み取りと読み解い
たんだと思います
私たち研究者は常に最先端の世界初の研究成果を求めています
もちろん私もそうです
誰も知らない現象目にし新しい世界を切り開いていこうとするときいつも私が思うこと
があります
それは科学の進歩はいつも必ず一の頭脳とてによる調整によってなされてきたという
こと
そしてその挑戦にはゴールがないんだということです
ゴールのない挑戦つまりテストで満点を想定しないような挑戦なんですから
万点からの減点方式で考えていたのでは決して成就しません
石眼的な目標設定してしまうと失敗を恐れて自ずと萎縮したチャレンジとなり
失敗は全て開くと評価されるため失敗から学ぶことができません
神の知的挑戦とは何かがわかったことあるいはこの方法ではできないとわかったこと
それらすべてを加点方式で考えるくらいのおおらかさと
そして決して諦めない果てしないチャレンジ精神が必要なんだと思います
そもそも新しい研究成果ですって言っていることだってそれは過去の研究成果の蓄積
火天の上に成り立ったものです
私たち研究者は研究成果を知的興奮と共に先輩の手から受け取ってそれを確実に次の
世代に受け渡していく責任ある存在なんだと思います
私は平凡な一研究者ですが不思議なものでそれでも
ラマン本によりもラマン分光学についてたくさんのことを知っています
私の研究室で研究者を目指している
20代の学生さん達だって今でこそ私より
知識も経験も乏しく未熟かもしれません
でも知的挑戦をやめない限り
将来私自身は決して知ることの叶わない新しい研究成果を得ることができると思います
私たち研究者の責任は研究成果を論文などの形で残し将来に託すことです
分かる形で研究成果を残してを記載すれば
たと今は評価されなくても将来誰かが私の研究に興味を持ってついでくれるかもしれ
ません
その時研究者は未来の研究者と研究上の新しいご縁によって結ばれることになると思い
ます
今私は研究者の経験を通してお話していますが
先達からの知識やチアを受け継いで次の世代に渡していく
ということは
人に誰でも共通した人の様のご縁がもたらすものなんだと思います
ラマンとの出会いは私自身の研究環境にも今や影響を与えています私は今
島根大学でインド人研究者と一緒に研究をしています
ラマン分光法について一緒に研究したい
っていう若いインド人研究者からメールがたくさん来るようになりました
インドとの国際共同研究も進んでいます
ラマンとのご縁は今やエンドとのインドとのご縁に混ぜ
広がってきました
今日私はノーベル賞を受賞した
インド人研究者らマンのこと
彼の発見
そしてその後の発展や応用についてご紹介しました
私はラーマンとのご縁そしてカレーの感謝を決して忘れません
そして研究をこれからも続けます
この話が皆さんご自身の周りのご縁について考えをめぐらし
そして
先達からの受けた後園
将来に託すべき大切な事柄について考えるきっかけになってくれると嬉しいです
最後まで聴いてくださってどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]